[Musique]
eh bien je veux dire tout est plus cher et
on est content si on quelque part quelque chose
peut sauver et qui s'est tenu ainsi
dans cette situation ça peut aider
eh bien vous pouvez imaginer que le
les prix de l'essence sont concernés et tendent et
le manquant doit bien sûr
allongé beaucoup plus chaque mois que
sinon
[Musique]
et bien sûr cela introduit aussi
défis que nous avons déjà
couleurs supplémentaires prévues à l'avance
sur certaines lignes, im 2 devient opérationnel
faut toujours regarder mais maintenant d'abord
attendre et voir comment ça se développe vraiment
nous l'attendons avec impatience et prenons-le
les gens aiment ça
convaincre également la nuit dans les maisons ou
rester cool sur le nom
[Musique]